Leute, guckt mal da, wir kriegen wieder 3 Ambit, habt ihr das gesehen?
Output, 4 Ambit, ohohoho, es funktioniert wieder, oh ey, meine Fresse, meine Fresse,
Internet in Deutschland ey, Internet in Deutschland, echt das ist nicht dritte Welt was wir sind,
das ist fünfte Welt, sechste Welt oder sowas, oder minus eins einte Welt ist das was wir
sind, oh man, ok, schauen wir mal, wo sind wir denn jetzt eigentlich stehen geblieben,
Sebaro ich hab's gesehen, ich hab gerade den Post gesehen, ok, sehr schön, also wo sind
wir stehen geblieben, wir haben den Raspberry Pi geflasht, die SD Karte geflasht, das ist
allerwichtigste, wir machen das aus Gequario mann, wir haben die SD Karte geflasht und
nun mach ich mal das in den Raspberry Pi rein, die SD Karte und mach die Elgato Capture Card
dran und dann schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert, ich bin, ich bin gespannt, dafür kann ich
jetzt auch mal mein Micro HDMI Kabel verwenden, was ich ja glücklicherweise noch von 2014
hatte, warum auch immer ich mir das damals gekauft hab, kennt ihr irgendein Gerät was
Micro HDMI verwendet, was 2014 angesagt war, vielleicht irgendwie der Wii U oder so hat
die Wii U Micro HDMI gehabt, für irgendwas muss ich mir 2014 eine Micro HDMI gekauft
haben, hm, für die Kamera, für den, ja für den Sony Camcorder vielleicht den ich damals
hatte, doch ich glaube wahrscheinlich für den Sony Camcorder, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich,
das andere fällt mir nicht ein, es muss für den Sony Camcorder gewesen sein, ok also,
stöpseln wir das mal rein, in den Pi, dann nehme ich meine Elgato, wo ist meine Elgato,
Elgato komm her, wo bist du, da und jetzt gucken wir erstmal ob die Elgato an sich funktioniert,
denn ich müsste jetzt, wenn das funktioniert, Game Capture, Call of Duty gehe ich ja ganz
kurz genau, add, warum habe ich denn hier keine Elgato mehr drinnen, ok wie dem auch sei,
dann füge ich mal wieder eine hinzu, add, Video Capture Device, yes, jawoll Game Capture
HD, Resolution, was passiert da jetzt wenn man da draufklickt, wenig, wenig passiert
da, ah, one moment please passiert da, ok, exellent, gut, dann sollte das eigentlich
jetzt klappen, so Chat haben wir auch am Start, ok, schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal ob das
jetzt funktioniert, ich mache jetzt den Raspberry dran, Strom an, wo ist der Input von der Elgato,
so alles angeschlossen, ich mach mal schnell Strom an Raspberry und gucke mal ob der Kram
funktioniert, das war Netzteil holen, zum Glück hat das Ding jetzt USB C, ok, der
Raspberry sollte jetzt angehen, der Raspberry geht an, geht die Elgato an, sollte da nicht
irgendwas passieren jetzt, sollte da nicht irgendwas passieren, ok, wir machen mal, ok
Properties, Config Video, No Signal, Input HDMI, PC, aber No Signal ist schlechter, das
sollte sich doch eigentlich alles automatisch einstellen, ok, dann machen wir das jetzt mal
anders, wir gehen mal hier zurück und machen jetzt mal die Game Capture Software an, gucken
ob das damit dann besser funktioniert, der sollte ein paar Sachen automatisch machen,
ah, oh fick dich, warum ist der Kram denn immer so ein Crapper, ach so, welchen HDMI
Eingang muss man beim Raspberry überhaupt verwenden, ist das egal, ich hab jetzt, ich
hab das Kabel jetzt, wartet mal, vielleicht ist es am falschen dran, den linken, ah,
ich hab den rechten, ok, ich stöpsel noch mal um, gibt es jetzt Signal, alter, also
der Raspberry ist gebootet, das funktioniert schon mal, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, funktioniert ja richtig gut, Capture Device, Remove, yes, da können wir das jetzt nämlich
aufmachen, hoffe ich, komm on brah, geh auf, ah, ok, da ist anscheinend echt nichts verbunden,
ich habs aber richtig dran, ich habs richtig dran, also man falsch anschließen kann man
das ja nicht, ich machs noch mal ab, so, jetzt mach ich noch mal wieder dran, Input, ey sag
bloß jetzt mein HDMI Kabel ist noch kaputt, da krieg ich Anfälle, die Capture Kader aus
und einstecken, können wir auch mal probieren, wir pusten mal, pusten hilft immer Leute,
bootet er überhaupt, sieht so aus, aber selbst wenn er nicht bootet, den Startbildschirm,
nämlich die Regenbogenfarbe, was, Connect your Device to get started, wtf, Capture Device
ist connected, das ist connected, ihr hört es doch, dass es connected ist, ich hab schon
wieder kein Bock mehr heute ey, das ist ja, Connect your Device to get started, was, natürlich
ist es device connected, was solls denn sonst sein, das ist sowas, das leuchtet sogar, dass
es connected ist, steck es mal direkt an den Monitor, ist schwierig, I know Capture Device
is found, Problem, kacke ey, ich stöpsel die Elgato mal an den anderen USB-Port, ich
stöpsel die Elgato mal an den anderen USB-Port, ich stöpsel die Elgato mal an den anderen
USB-Port, ich stöpsel die Elgato mal an den anderen USB-Port, ich stöpsel die Elgato
Also der Raspberry ist gebootet, der hat auch...
Okay, das hat alles keinen Bock.
Das jebaitet mich.
Also nix...
Aha.
Ich hab's jetzt grad nochmal rausgesteckt.
Und nochmal reingemacht, anscheinend...
Jetzt ist er anscheinend der Meinung, da geht was.
Ich hab's jetzt zum fünften Mal rein rausgesteckt,
jetzt scheint es zu funktionieren.
Excellent.
High IQ.
Place.
No Signal.
Warum?
Sag bloß das HDMI-Kabel ist kaputt.
Okay, Raspberry...
Also eins muss der Raspberry auf jeden Fall machen.
Der muss seinen komischen Regenbogen-Bootscreen anzeigen.
Andersherum geht das nicht.
Ich hab jetzt nochmal einen ausgeschaltet.
Da tut sich nix.
Wisst ihr was Leute, ich glaube...
Das HDMI-Kabel ist kaputt.
Ich kotze ey.
Funktioniert nix heute.
Erst ist Vodafone am Abspacken
und jetzt funktioniert noch nicht mal das Bildschirmcaptchern.
Wahnsinn.
So, wo hab ich denn mein...
Wo hab ich denn mein HDMI-Hub?
Fürs Display.
Ich hab nicht noch eins, nein, das ist das einzige.
Das ist ein Mikro-HDMI-Kabel.
Wer hat überhaupt Mikro-HDMI-Kabel?
Ich hab davon nur eins.
Settings.
Standard.
Mobile.
Was auch immer ich hier umstelle, macht eigentlich überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Arthur.
Standard.
Eigentlich ist es ziemlich egal, was ich da einstelle, oder?
Echt, ihr habt Mikro-HDMI-Kabel?
Ich kenn niemand, der Mikro-HDMI-Kabel hat.
Wo habt ihr so viele Mikro-HDMI-Kabel?
Okay, machen wir mal was anderes.
Ich mach ne andere SD-Karte rein in den Raspberry.
Ich mach ne andere SD-Karte rein.
Ich hab noch eine mit nem Linux drauf,
da müsste zumindest der Text-Modus booten.
Probieren wir das mal aus.
Andere SD-Karte rein, gucken wir mal.
Also, ich hab jetzt HDMI, ich hab den HDMI-Anschluss genommen
neben dem USB-C für den Strom, ne?
Ich denke mal, das ist richtig.
Which HDMI-Port?
One or two.
Was ist HDMI-Null?
Das ist richtig, HDMI-Null, okay.
HDMI-Null, warum macht der kein Autodetekt beim Start?
Ach, da steht's doch, hier, USB.
Okay, dann machen wir mal was anderes.
Also, das da einmal.
Dann gehen wir mal von aus, dass das richtig ist,
weil ich eingestellt hab.
Okay, dann starten wir das mal mit der Linux,
mit dem Raspbian drauf.
Zumindest die Commando-Zeile müsste er starten.
Er müsste den Port anmachen.
Nee, ne?
Juckt ihn überhaupt gar nicht.
Ist ihm absolut scheißegal.
Ich glaub, das Kabel ist kaputt.
Ich glaub, mein HDMI-Kabel ist kaputt.
Also, da kann ich mir das jetzt nicht erklären.
Ich überleg grad, ob ich was anderes mal per HDMI
anschließen kann, um zu gucken, ob's funktioniert.
Hab ich hier eine Konsole grad dran?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, ich hab die alle abgemacht.
Nee, ich hab keine Konsole.
Aber die Capture-Card geht.
Ich weiß, dass die hatten wir schon so oft im Stream hier.
Die ist okay.
Dass die kein Input erkennt, das Kabel ist wahrscheinlich im Arsch.
Steckt das Kabel hier?
Steckt das Kabel mal in den Monitor?
Das kann ich ausprobieren, ja.
Ich hab die Capture-Card nochmal rein rausgemacht.
Die Capture-Software ist auch ganz schön fail, oder?
Wenn die nicht erkennt, dass man hier...
Dass man die Capture-Card anschließt.
Was ist los mit dem Ding?
Kack.
Aber ich stöpsel's mal in...
Ich stöpsel's mal im Monitor.
Aber eigentlich hab ich schon gar keinen Bock mehr weiterzumachen.
Ähm, in welchem Monitor steck ich's denn mal?
Hier, da haben wir doch ein HDMI-Kabel.
Hat das grad irgendwie drei Stunden gedauert, bis er die Capture-Card erkannt hat?
Kann das sein?
Der braucht eine halbe Stunde, bis er die Capture-Card erkannt hat.
Ist der mit's?
What the fuck?
Okay, ich mach's jetzt mal im Monitor rein.
Okay, das passt mit dem Kabel.
Jetzt muss ich das Kabel erstmal entführen.
Okay.
Dann schalte ich mal den Monitor um.
Ob's funktioniert, aber es wird nicht funktionieren.
Ich kann's mir einfach nicht vorstellen.
Gut, HDMI 1.
No signal detected.
Exzellent.
So mag ich das.
Kauf dir einen Elgato-Cab-Link.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es an der Capture-Card liegt, Leute.
Entweder ist der Raspberry Pi-Spakt rum, oder...
Ich hab ne Idee.
Ich hab hier noch einen Pi 3.
Der hat einen Mini-HDMI.
Wo hab ich den Raspberry Pi 3?
Hier.
Ich hab noch einen Raspberry Pi 3.
Der hat einen ganz normalen Full-Size-HDMI.
Ja wunderbar, dann probieren wir das mal mit dem Raspberry Pi 3 aus.
Mal gucken, was da passiert in der Capture-Card.
Erstmal wieder hier Display umschalten.
Ich weiß, es ist grad bestimmt huge spannend, sich das jetzt grad anzugucken, alles.
So, also mal hier wieder rausmachen.
Aber ich mein, wer kennt's nicht, ne?
So.
Jetzt machen wir mal den Raspberry Pi 3 dran, mit einem HDMI-Kabel.
Da brauch ich jetzt nur noch ein HDMI-Kabel.
Wo fliegt hier noch ein HDMI-Kabel rum?
Ein richtig echtes HDMI-Kabel.
Massive.
Leute, ich zeig euch mal nebenbei das ASCII-Quarium.
Da könnt ihr euch dann ein bisschen an ASCII-Fischen erfreuen.
Jetzt brauch ich noch ein HDMI-Kabel, was auf beiden Seiten HDMI-kabelig ist.
Wo hab ich denn da eins?
Wartet mal, ich muss mal gucken, wo hab ich denn da eins?
Wartet mal, ich muss mal kurz wühlen gehen.
Meine Güte, das ist ein Act.
Strom.
Kein HDMI.
Wo hab ich da ein HDMI-Kabel?
Ich hab hier irgendwo eins noch.
Ah.
Excellent.
Das originale, Leute, das originale Xbox One 2013 Release-HDMI-Kabel.
Hoffentlich geht das.
Kein, kein Fake, kein Fake, kein Fake, kein Fake, kein Fake.
Das ist das.
Kein Fake, das originale, ja.
Okay, dann stöpseln wir mal das hier in die Elgato rein und gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Huge Debugging Stream.
Massive.
So.
Jetzt brauch ich Strom.
Ah, der normale Raspberry, der hat ja jetzt Mikro-HDMI-Strom.
Da komm ich jetzt mit dem USB-C-Strom nicht weiter hin.
Und Lightning-Anschluss bringt uns nichts.
Ah.
So, Netzteil.
So.
Der Raspberry macht auch nichts.
Also jetzt bin ich echt ein wenig überfragt.
Es wird doch nicht das HDMI-Kabel, HDMI-Kabel gehen nicht kaputt.
Aus Prinzip, HDMI-Kabel gehen nicht kaputt.
Nie gesehen, dass HDMI-Kabel kaputt ist.
So, ich tauche jetzt nochmal das USB-Kabel aus zur Elgato Capture Card.
Vielleicht bringt das ja was.
Und dann habe ich keinen Bock mehr, wenn das nichts bringt.
Wir könnten noch was testen.
Ich stöpsel so mal an die Playstation dran.
Okay, das braucht irgendwie 5 Stunden.
Das braucht irgendwie 5 Stunden, bis die Capture Card erkannt hat.
Ey.
Wahnsinn.
Was hast du gegen meinen Desktop?
Ich habe jetzt in dem Raspberry Pi 3 habe ich die SD-Karte drin.
Warum braucht ihr 3 Stunden, bis er die Elgato Capture Card erkennt?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Heck.
Das funktioniert ja heute wieder wirklich exzellent.
Ich mache jetzt nochmal in den Raspberry Pi 3 die SD-Karte rein, wo ich weiß, dass
es funktioniert.
Oh.
So, das bringt uns jetzt aber nichts.
Das bringt uns jetzt aber nichts.
Weil das ist der falsche Raspberry Pi.
Der falsche Raspberry Pi und die falsche SD-Karte.
Das ist die Kombination, die uns absolut nichts bringt, dass sie funktioniert.
Okay, also dann gehen wir jetzt nochmal systematisch vor.
Also wir haben jetzt einen Raspberry Pi.
Wir haben jetzt eine Kombination.
Also die Capture Card funktioniert definitiv.
Das heißt, was wir jetzt probieren, ist die gleiche SD-Karte mit dem Micro HDMI Kabel
im Raspberry Pi 4.
Weil eine andere Kombination kann ich gerade nicht machen.
Oder wir probieren die neue SD-Karte im Raspberry Pi, der funktioniert.
Weil dann können wir ausschließen, dass die SD-Karte im Arsch ist.
Und wahrscheinlich ist die SD-Karte auch nicht richtig von mir formatiert.
Aber der neue Raspberry müsste zumindest auch an der Elgato starten.
Huge Resolution sehe ich hier gerade.
Kann man das nicht ordentlich einstellen?
Ja, das sieht auch schon ein bisschen besser aus.
Löte dir ein neues Kabel, easy.
So, jetzt machen wir die andere SD-Karte nochmal rein.
Leute, die andere SD-Karte kann glaube ich nicht funktionieren.
Weil machen die das nicht so, dass wenn die SD-Karte mal im Raspberry Pi 4 gewesen ist,
dass die dann die Karte resize und dass die ganze Bootgeschichte dann für Raspberry Pi 4 ist,
dass es auf dem 3er gar nicht mehr bootet.
Weil da geht gar nichts an mit der SD-Karte drin.
Wenn ich die gleiche SD-Karte im Pi 4 drin habe, dann bootet da wenigstens.
Ok, dann machen wir jetzt noch eins.
Wir wissen, dass die Elgato funktioniert.
Das heißt, wir stöpseln jetzt so wie es ist.
Was im Pi 3 funktioniert, stöpseln wir jetzt an den Pi 4 und gucken, ob es dann auch funktioniert.
Und wenn das funktioniert, probieren wir nochmal das andere.
Huge professional stream.
So, wo ist das Mikro HDMI?
Wo ist das Mikro HDMI Kabel?
Alter, wo habe ich das denn jetzt?
Hier.
So, macht er was?
Nee, oder?
Juckt ihn nicht.
Also, ich glaube, das HDMI Kabel ist kaputt.
Ja.
Ja gut, dann...
Ja gut, Leute.
Also, der Raspberry Pi 4 bootet. Ich sehe, dass der an ist.
WLAN ist auch an.
Das HDMI Kabel geht nicht.
Das ist aber doof.
Also, ich habe jetzt nicht damit gerechnet, dass das HDMI Kabel im Arsch ist bei der ganzen Konstruktion, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich meine, wir können es mit dem...
Der Kram läuft aber glaube ich nicht auf dem Raspberry Pi 3, ne?
Der ist ex...
Der hat glaube ich explizit geschrieben, dass das nur auf dem Pi 4 funktioniert.
Ja.
Tja, dann liegt es wohl daran, dass mein Mikro HDMI Kabel kaputt ist.
Wo wir dann beim Thema sind, wir brauchen noch ein Mikro HDMI Kabel.
So was da.
Zur Kasse gehen.
Zum Glück habe ich noch nicht bestellt.
Das, was man am wenigsten erwartet, tatsächlich. Also, dass das Mikro HDMI Kabel im Arsch ist, habe ich echt nicht gedacht.
Ziemlicher...
Ziemlicher Fail ist eigentlich.
Hast du ein neues Mikro? Ne, ne, ne. Ist immer das gleiche. Das Einzige, was habe ich ein bisschen Kompressor angemacht.
Tja.
Ich meine, es war eh nur just for fun, weil ich gucken wollte, ob es irgendwie funktioniert.
Und wie es aussieht, ich hatte ja eh keinerlei Anwendungszweck für.
Aber so ein bisschen ärgert mich das jetzt schon, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Was hat er noch? Was hat er noch Mikro HDMI?
Was hat er noch Mikro HDMI?
Dass ich das ausprobieren kann.
Ich habe nichts mehr mit Mikro HDMI. Ein iPad hat kein Mikro HDMI Kamera.
Habe ich den olden Sony Camcorder, für den ich das wahrscheinlich gekauft habe.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo das Ding ist.
Ich weiß echt nicht, wo ich das hin habe. Das verwende ich auch nicht mehr.
Das iPhone hat auch keinen.
Das...
Das Fire?
Das Fire HD? Haben die Mikro HDMI? Nee, oder?
Hat das?
Nee, oder? Haben die Fire HD?
Haben die Mikro HDMI? Bestimmt nicht, oder?
Ich glaube nicht.
GoPro? Ich habe kein GoPro, nee.
Ah nee, da hat er USB-C.
Den Camcorder? Ich hätte nur den Sony Camcorder zu bieten.
Und ich habe wirklich keinen Schimmer, wo der ist.
Wo habe ich den?
Ich gucke mal kurz auf den Schrank hier oben drauf, aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich den da habe.
Den habe ich schon ewig, wirklich ewig nicht mehr verwendet.
Und wenn ist der Akku leer?
Nee.
Der kam.
Nee Leute, keine Ahnung, wo ich den habe.
Den habe ich wahrscheinlich beim Aufräumen irgendwo reingeschmissen, weil ich den eh nicht verwende.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber warum ist das HDMI-Kabel kaputt? Das ist die logischste Variante.
Der Pi 4 bootet. Die Elgato geht auch in dem Setup.
Elgato HD 60, Mikro HDMI. Mal gucken, ob es da bekannte Fehler gibt.
Aber eigentlich nicht, HDMI ist HDMI.
Pi 4.
Das muss gehen. Das HDMI-Kabel ist im Arsch. Das ist die logischste Erklärung dafür, die ich habe.
Und auch die sinnvollste Erklärung, weil es funktioniert ja.
Das Kabel war sauber. Ehrlich zu sein nicht.
Was soll da? Ich habe mal reingepustet. Was soll da? Du siehst ja hier.
Ich kann doch mal reinpusten. Ja, ich habe es direkt am Monitor probiert. Geht auch nicht.
Also entweder ist mein Pi 4 kaputt, was ich nicht glaube.
Oder das HDMI-Kabel ist kaputt. Wahrscheinlich ist das HDMI-Kabel kaputt.
Doch, ich könnte mit einem Multimeter messen, aber damit fange ich jetzt nicht an.
Ich puste nochmal in das Kabel rein. Große Puste-Aktion machen wir jetzt noch.
Juckt ihn nicht. Juckt ihn absolut nicht.
Eine Idee habe ich noch, was wir machen.
Wir flashen ein ganz normales Raspbian, nur um auf Nummer sicher zu gehen, dass der Pi auch bootet.
Wir flashen ein ganz normales Raspbian auf die SD-Karte.
Ganz normales Raspbian ohne irgendwas. Flashen wir auf die SD-Karte.
Wo ist es hier? Download, Download-Lite.
Und gucken wir mal, ob es funktioniert. Aber der Raspberry bootet. Ich sehe das.
Man sieht ja immer, wenn das grüne Licht an geht, dann connectet er zum W-Lan und so.
Ja, das glaube ich nicht, dass das was damit zu tun hat.
Hast du keinen HDMI-Tester, um ehrlich zu sein, nicht? Nee.
10 Monate, huge. Sorry Leute, falls ich irgendwelche Subs übersehen habe, muss ich jetzt mal gucken.
Massive IQ-Sub. Ich gucke gerade mal, ob ich irgendwas übersehen habe.
So, Steamlabs mag nicht.
Recent Events.
Nee, habe ich nichts übersehen. Zum Glück.
Also wo ist hier der Download? Download ist fertig. Dann flashen wir das schnell.
Ja, das war die Capture-Karte. Egal. Erstmal flashen. Stinken wir mal das Raspbian drauf, ohne extra Würste.
Und dann booten wir das. Da müssen wir auch kein...
Da müssen wir auch nichts...
Was?
Alter, will ich verarschen? Disconnect.
Mach das doch mal please in die VM, wo ich drinnen bin.
Select, Downloads. Was haben wir da? Raspbian Buster Lite. Perfekt.
Ist das wirklich so alt, was ich da habe? Habe ich das Kanon runtergeladen?
13.02. Okay, na gut. Flash.
Warum machst du es nicht mit DD? Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe gestern auch einem erzählt, wie er seine Festplatte schön löscht mit DD.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich es nicht bei DD mache. Kann ich nicht erklären.
Hat keinen tieferen Sinn. DD ist genauso gut.
Der Haube macht das andere auch nicht besser.
So.
Gut, wenn das fertig geflashed ist, starte ich noch mal den Raspbian und gucke, ob der als Inferer damit läuft.
Wenn es da nicht läuft, dann ist es definitiv das HDMI-Kabel, was im Arsch ist.
Das mini HDMI-Kabel.
Kann man auf dem Pi 4 irgendeine Startoption setzen, dass der HDMI einschaltet?
Nee, das wäre bescheuert. Stell dir mal vor, du hast keinen zweiten Rechner, du hast nur einen Raspbian.
Den kannst du ja gar nicht einschalten.
Das wäre komplett hängen geblieben. Geht alles automatisch. Das muss auch automatisch gehen.
Das wäre komplett hängen geblieben, wenn du erst einen zweiten Rechner brauchst, dass du es in Betrieb nehmen kannst.
Gucken wir uns noch ein paar Fragen an, die ich übersehen habe.
Null zu das normale Raspberry-Netzteil für den 4. Nee, das geht nicht.
Das normale ist, es hat ja ein Mikro HDMI.
Mit dem Adapter könnte ich es benutzen. Nee, ich habe zwei.
Ich habe einen Raspberry-4-Netzteil und einen Raspberry-3-Netzteil.
Im Prinzip kannst du für Raspberry Pi oder generell für die Dinge fast jeden USB nehmen.
Nur je nach USB-Controller gibt es manchmal ein bisschen wenig Strom.
Aber kein Problem, also geht.
Wie gesagt, ich habe zwei Netzteile.
5 Volt, 3 Ampere Netzteile, die Standard-Dinger.
Die stecken direkt in der Steckdose, daran kann es nicht liegen.
Am Cam Link klickst du garantiert auch nicht.
Einfach PSA Sound, VNC. Ich könnte auch X-Forboding machen.
Wieso hat das Kartellkram zugelassen? Frag sie mal.
How to survive in Frankfurt.
Leute, wisst ihr eigentlich, wie gefährlich ich lebe? Überlegt euch das mal.
Überlegt euch das mal, was in letzter Zeit los ist.
Ich wohne quasi in Hanau und ich arbeite in Frankfurt.
In Hanau werden regelmäßig Leute umgebracht gerade.
Und in Frankfurt ist die gefährlichste Stadt Deutschlands.
Wie überlebe ich das überhaupt?
Eigentlich gar nicht möglich, oder?
Leider wirklich so.
Ja, es ist gefährlich.
Ohne Spaß, hätte Assi Toni da jetzt gesagt.
Also hier ist wirklich was los in letzter Zeit.
Jetzt noch nicht im positiven Sinn.
Moment, wo habe ich das Pepega-Board?
Moment.
Habe ich das jetzt gelöscht?
Ach nee, hier.
Speedtest.
Ja, den Vortrag kenne ich, der ist richtig gut.
Den könnten wir uns irgendwann, wenn wir viel Zeit haben, zusammen nochmal angucken.
Das liegt bestimmt an Vodafone, ich glaube nicht, dass es an dir liegt.
Warum glaubt jeder, dass es mit Glasfaser besser wird?
Die Anschlusstechnik hat ja damit eigentlich gar nichts zu tun.
Bei Vodafone liegt es ja auch eher nicht daran, dass die Probleme von mir zu Vodafone sind,
sondern in der Anbindung von Vodafone zum Rest, da würde Glasfaser auch nichts bringen.
Aber wo Glasfaser was bringen würde, ist bei der Telekom,
wo die ganze Sache deutlich besser läuft als bei Vodafone.
Allerdings bei mir die Technik lahmer ist als Vodafone.
Da wäre es natürlich cool.
Celso von Minecraft.
Hype-Game, was zwischenzeitlich nicht mehr gehype war und jetzt wieder ein bisschen im Hype ist.
Und im Kern wahrscheinlich nicht schlecht, aber ich bin ich nie so richtig mit warm geworden.
Muss ich machen, ja.
Ach, das war noch von gestern.
Also, na komm, also Minecraft ist das Hype-Game schlechthin gewesen.
So auch Jahre lang, aber ein Hype kann doch auch mehrere Jahre gehen.
Also das ist kein Problem.
Minecraft gleich Java.
Natürlich kann auch was über längere Zeitraum gehyped werden.
Guck dir, was weiß ich, Battlefield 3 hat oder guck dir Game of Thrones an.
Fucking Game of Thrones, das war auch 5 Jahre gehyped oder wie lang das lief.
Cyberpunk, na Cyberpunk ist wirklich gehyped gerade.
Ja, schau dir die Definition von Hype an, aber es ist ja unabhängig von der Definition.
Sowas wie Game of Thrones ist auch 5 Jahre am Stück Ultra gehyped.
Wie würdest du es denn nennen, wenn nicht gehyped?
Hat einen besonders hohen, einen breiten Zuspruch in der Bevölkerung oder wie?
So, ist das Flaschen jetzt durch? Hat es fertig geflasht?
Ho, fertig geflasht.
Ja, erfolgreich ist es auf jeden Fall.
Erfolgreich ist das Game auf jeden Fall.
Aber es gibt wenig Games, die auf YouTube und auf anderen Plattformen so viele Leute angezogen haben,
rein durch die Existenz auf manchen Channels.
Vielleicht noch Fortnite jetzt, aber da muss man mal sehen, wie lange der Kram läuft.
So, fertig geflasht.
Sync.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie das mit Fortnite weiterläuft.
Aktuell ist Fortnite ja ein bisschen so den Hate Train.
Aktuell ist es Fortnite ein bisschen das, was vor ein paar Jahren, wo sich alle an Call of Duty abgearbeitet haben,
so nach dem Motto, alles was sie releasen ist Scheiße und es hätte besser sein können.
So ein Crap, die hätten mal ihren Game Designer nicht feuern sollen.
Aktuell kriegt Fortnite übelst viel Shit ab.
Ich weiß nicht, ob zu Recht oder zu Unrecht, wahrscheinlich sogar zu Recht.
Das kann ich nicht beurteilen als jemand, der absolut keine Ahnung von Fortnite hat
und auch nicht vorhat, Fortnite jetzt irgendwie zu spielen.
So.
Nein, nein, nein, die Elgato, die darf schön am Host connected bleiben.
One moment please.
Gut Leute, dann stöpsel ich das mal in den Raspberry Pi 4 rein und wir gucken, ob sich da was tut.
Und?
Tut sich was?
Nein.
Gut.
Das heißt für mich endgültig Leute, das HDMI Kabel ist im Arsch.
Das Mikro HDMI Kabel ist kaputt.
Da gibt es jetzt für mich keinerlei oder sehr wenig Zweifel nur noch dran.
RIP.
HDMI Kabel.
Vm.
Heute nicht mehr.
Aber es ist das erste Mal, kommst du über SSH drauf?
Ja jetzt gerade nicht mehr, weil die neue SD Karte hat weder SSH aktiviert noch WLAN eingerichtet.
Ich habe noch nie ein kaputtes HDMI Kabel gehabt.
Das ist echt Premiere.
Vielleicht war das auch der Grund, warum das bei mir hinter dem Rechner rumhing jahrelang unbeachtet.
Vielleicht war es ja von Anfang an kaputt.
Ich weiß, dass ich das machen kann.
Aber das habe ich auf der SD Karte erst nicht gemacht.
Ich will das nicht nochmal umstöpseln.
Es ist auch vollkommen egal, ob das funktioniert.
Mit dem anderen HDMI Kabel im Raspberry Pi 3 funktioniert es ja.
Das muss das Mikro HDMI Kabel sein.
Andere logische Erklärungen gibt es da nicht für.
Aber ich habe jetzt ja eins bestellt.
Kann man das irgendwann demnächst nochmal ausprobieren, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Ja sagt, aber gut.
Machste nix.
Da machste nix.
Sollen wir mal die ganzen Questions hier weghauen?
Kennst du was? Achso, das war von gestern.
Minecraft gleich Java. Ich glaube sogar, dass es bei Minecraft ausnahmsweise ein Vorteil war, dass der Kram in Java programmiert wurde.
Weil dadurch konnten so viele Plugins für die Server erstellt werden, wie es mit C++ wahrscheinlich nicht der Fall gewesen wäre.
Was hast du eigentlich gegen Java? Ich sage ja nichts Wirksames.
Nix, eigentlich gar nichts.
Außer, dass ich gerne Flame. Aber eigentlich habe ich nix gegen Java. Nicht so wirklich.
Das Pepega Board, da wäre nicht schlecht, wenn das Datum drin stehen würde.
Microsoft header.
Alle Fragen weg.
Eben war es. Hat es wieder geruckelt?
Glaube ich nicht. Das hätte ich gesehen in meiner Vorschau, wenn es eben geruckelt hätte.
Nö, funktioniert wunderbar.
War das etwa ein?
Ein Gebate-Versuch.
Ja, hat heute leider nicht so gut funktioniert.
Aber was willst du machen, ja?
Wer rechnet mit einem kaputten HDMI-Kabel?
Wer rechnet mit einem kaputten HDMI-Kabel? Da hätte ich ja echt im Leben nicht dran gedacht.
Ja, doof.
Aber trotzdem, schön, dass bei einem Stream, wo eigentlich im Endeffekt nichts passiert ist, außer, dass es nicht funktioniert hat.
Trotzdem so 140, 150 Leute am Start waren. Neiße Geschichte.
Mikro HDMI ist richtig crap.
Ich gehe jetzt auf.
Wollen wir noch Outro-Musik haben?
Muss Outro-Musik heute?
Salami.
Also, wir sehen uns dann, die Tage.
Ich habe übrigens die ganze Zeit immer noch die falsche Overlay hier angehabt. Das ist das richtige Overlay.
Also, bis denn. Macht's gut. C-Uhr.
C-Uhr.